veamos si podemos hallar la solución de
la ecuación p cuadrada
igual a 0.81 muy bien ahora bien esta
ecuación que hemos planteado podemos
verlo de otra forma podríamos verlo de
la forma p igual a más o menos la raíz
cuadrada de 0.81 verdad ya lo hemos
visto en otros vídeos que estas dos son
expresiones equivalentes verdad y aquí
por supuesto p puede ser tanto la raíz
principal que sería la raíz positiva o
puede ser la raíz negativa verdad ahora
bien
si nosotros pensáramos no en 0.81 sino
en el 81 digamos sin sin punto decimal
nosotros podríamos ver fácilmente que 9
por 9 es igual a 81 verdad eso lo
tenemos muy bien conocido u otra forma
de escribirlo es 9 al cuadrado es igual
a 81 o bien podríamos decir que 9 es la
raíz principal de 81 verdad la raíz
cuadrada principal de 81 y estas tres
expresiones son equivalentes ahora bien
nosotros no tenemos 81 si no tenemos
0.81 pero lo que sí sabemos es que si
por ejemplo tomáramos un
un número que tenga un dígito a la
derecha después del punto decimal al
multiplicarlo consigo mismo dos veces
tendríamos un número con dos decimales a
la derecha del punto verdad como es el
caso que tenemos aquí del 0.81 entonces
qué pasaría si nosotros probamos con 0.9
en lugar de 9 bueno si nosotros elevamos
al cuadrado estamos pensando en
multiplicar 0.9 por 0.9 verdad y esto
bueno tenemos un número un dígito perdón
a la derecha del punto decimal y aquí
también eso nos dará un número con dos
dígitos a la derecha del punto decimal
entonces 9 por 9 es 81 pero ese tiene
que estar 2 deben ser dos dígitos a la
derecha del punto decimal entonces aquí
hoy tenemos que la raíz cuadrada
y 0.81 es 0.9 de verdad y de hecho
pudimos haber tomado el 0.9 o menos 0.9
no importa verdad entonces esto que
teníamos escrito acá de este lado
simplemente lo podemos ver como que p es
igual a más o menos la raíz cuadrada de
0.9 al cuadrado verdad 0.9 al cuadrado y
pude haber puesto también menos no
importa no importa el signo ya que lo
vamos a elevar al cuadrado pero de todos
modos tampoco importa porque te va a ser
tanto la parte positiva como la parte
negativa entonces como conclusión de
esto podríamos decir que p
puede ser 0.9 o bien que p puede ser
menos
punto 9 verdad y tú podrías verificarlo
por tu propia cuenta si elevado al
cuadrado a 0.9 o al menos 0.9 el
resultado se debe de dar 0.81